The action-packed trailer for DC's Suicide
Squad movie took fans by storm, revealing
new scenes, new characters, and even more
hard-hitting humor. But it also packed in
more easter eggs, comic book nods, and hidden
touches that viewers probably missed. We've
made sure to catch them all, so we hope you
enjoy The Suicide Squad Official Trailer ALL
EASTER EGGS You Missed.
Bravo
Viewers were probably more interested in the
characters inside the prison uniforms than
the writing on them, but the orange uniforms
confirm that the movie's heroes are detainees
of "Site Bravo" - apparently the codename
for Bell Reve prison. The name itself doesn't
reveal a ton about the story, but it explains
why director David Ayer chose the name "Bravo
14" for the title of the movie while in production.
The 14, well... we're open to theories.
Special Delivery
While the villains like Deadshot and Harley
Quinn are transported to what looks to be
an army base before their mission, the rabid
Boomerang is a different story. He bursts
from his sack and into a figh so fast, viewers
might have missed the joke: it was no ordinary
bag, but an Australia Post mailbag, a nod
to the famous villain's Aussie roots.
Tailcoats
Whether you're a crazed criminal or not, any
truly formal occasion demands a tuxedo - or
in this case, a tailcoat - but the white tie
and carnation capping off the look are a clear
reference to one famous image of Joker and
Harley Quinn, painted by noted comic artist
Alex Ross.
Mr. Frost
A single shot of the trailer shows actor Jim
Parrack acting as a hired gun or henchman
for Joker. But pay attention to the name on
his sleeve, and you'll notice he's no random
henchman: that's Jonny Frost, the Joker's
right hand man who narrates Brian Azzarello's
hit "Joker" graphic novel.
Midway
Keep your eyes peeled as the action of the
trailer unfolds, and you'll catch a few different
signs that show it's all set in the fictional
location of Midway City (on police car Deadshot's
jumping over). Loosely based on Chicago, the
DC city is most famous for being the home
of two Justice League heroes, Hawkman and
Hawkgirl.
Katana's Katana
Samurai swords are nothing new to fans of
martial arts films or comic books, but the
one wielded by Katana is one of a kind. Known
as the 'Soultaker' sword, the blade has the
mystical ability to absorb every soul whose
life it has ever taken. This one shot reveals
how the filmmakers will be showing the souls
contained within Soultaker, as spectral skulls
radiating off of the blade like heat.
If that weren't enough, Katana is also able
to commune with any of the spirits residing
in her blade. In the trailer, it looks like
she's doing exactly that, with her eyes fading
from completely white to completely black
to show the link has been made. At least,
we hope that's what we're watching.
Fists of Fury
Batman has his Batarangs, Catwoman has her
whip, and Deadshot has his wrist-mounted firearms.
Although they began as weapons of imagination
in the pages of DC Comics, the firearms team
for Suicide Squad has come through with flying
colors, bringing to life one scene that fans
of the ruthless assassin have been hoping
to see adapted to the big screen for years.
Harley's Rebirth
Seeing the Joker takeanotherjump into
a vat of chemicals seems pointless, until
you realize that he's headed in to retrieve
Harley Quinn. The scene perfectly mirrors
the New 52 origin of Harley, where Joker slowly
manipulated her to his way of thinking, before
tossing her into the same chemicals that created
his twisted mind, and seeing Harley Quinn
emerge.
Latin Wisdom
The last laugh of the trailer goes to Harley
Quinn, who smashes a store window in the middle
of a suicide mission. But take a closer look
at the mannequin in the store, and you'll
see the same Latin phrase repeated over and
over: "si vis pacem para bellum." Translated,
the phrase means "if you want peace, prepare
for war." Somehow, we think that the Squad's
mastermind, Amanda Waller would absolutely
agree.
Those are the easter eggs, secrets and awesome
touches we spotted in the Suicide Squad trailer,
but which ones did we miss? Let us known in
the comments, and remember to subscribe to
our channel for more videos like this one.